the fluffing that they were doing you
know we saw this recently the last
couple weeks you know where we had like
we sometimes have a broad panel where
it's like early 20s all the way up to
like late 30s even 40s we've had a
couple of 50 year olds you know 50 plus
and it's like there'll be a 41 year- Old
on and there's a couple of younger gals
on and they'll say something immediately
like you know because when we go around
at the intro it's you know how old are
you you know why'd you come on the show
where do you live sort of thing you was
a quick intro and then like right away
oh my God you're so you know you're soti
I would have guessed that you were you
know 28 years old and not 42 so it's
like come on like you know can we stop
playing the games and have an honest
conversation rather than telling
somebody that's clearly looking like
they're in their 40s that they're you
know 28 or 29 or something like that and
I think that you know the
honesty I mean a lot more honesty would
go a long way but I don't think that
you're ever going to get it from you
know from the gals they're they're
always going to fluff each other up I
mean that's why you have this um New
Found culture of the uh uh fat
acceptance movement right where it's
like you know people that are un like
categorically unhealthy they probably
have cardiovascular disease maybe
diabetes definitely obese uh they've
probably got chronic joint pain all
kinds of problems that sort of compound
with that and you just tell them oh but
you're beautiful at any size right well
no you're not and also you've got health
issues so why don't we just be honest
about that sort of stuff but um you seem
to get that a lot more with women than
you do guys you know guys will just be
honest I'll just say you know I'll you
know I'll I'll be with one of the boys
like we were at Breen Ridge last year
and you know they'll be standing there
with their shirt off it's like what the
hell is this man you're skinny fat like
you're shaped like a pair of fixes you
know you can't be hanging around us
looking like that right and it's like
you know the guy will take it to hard to
be like yeah you're right you know you
know I'll fix that but we're but we as
men end up being direct and honest like
I think that's that's certainly one of
the big distinguishing differences
between men and women as far as the way
that we approach um you know stories and
you know the novelty of these sort of
sorts of conversations and I think that
maybe we take that for granted sometimes
as guys whereas you know you you do the
Ladies Night Show and you watch some
sort of like do their thing and you're
like oh there it is again right there it
is again well it's always about
competition between women I mean there's
really not this the the the reason that
we know why women aren't honest with
another because it's all about
intersexual competition is they want to
compete with the top shelf guys so if
they can get women to continue to be
ugly or be fat or look old but try to
convince them that they're skinny and
young and attractive then there's no
work that goes into that there's no need
to change I saw something on Twitter
today where they were talking about
short hair did you see it there was a
study done on hair hairdressers and
female hairdressers are more likely to
encourage a woman to cut her hair short
if she's beautiful to to try to
disqualify her from the sexual
Marketplace because we know that you
know men find long hair feminine more
attractive a sign of youthfulness and
fertility um but female hairdressers
will encourage beautiful women to cut
their hair short um to try to disqualify
them I I found that fascinating yeah I
didn't which is right in line with what
you're talking about right there right I
mean it's they hold a lot of power
because you know look man you I don't
know if you guys have seen she get
haircuts but it's always funny when a
girl gets a haircut and she gets like an
inch or two cut off and you're like you
don't know any difference but to them
it's you might as well a buzz cut yeah
so I mean you know six seven inches
eight inches of hair is years of of hair
growth and so but this idea it's all
about competition but somebody you I
made that comment I think once on X and
somebody said well what about you know
men like aren't men always competing
with women I said yes but the difference
is that
it's a it's like a necessary evil you
know men will go further when they have
a tribe of strong masculine competent
men and it's important to have that for
the advancement of tribes and Society
so because a lot of guys say oh well why
are you gu aren't you guys happy with
80% of men being dorks and L like
wouldn't you rather just tell men to get
fat and not Chase Excellence it's like
well no because there's it's a net
positive when you have strong virtuous
masul raise All Ships right correct so
as you're advancing Society where
there's never that necessity for women
because good luck pitting a female tribe
against a male tribe we already know how
that's played out in for Millennia so
they really only have competition in in
in girl world where it breaks each other
down and it's about it's far more blood
thirsty than it is in the male World
figuratively speaking but at least when
it comes to
guys competing competition creates
stronger men which creates a better
Society competition for women is all
about just getting the next best guy so
she can be taken care of it's very
solipsistic when you talk about female
competition it's all about her hypergamy
male competition is about building
tribes and advancing Society forward so
you know we we see that as a net
positive even though we're building up
men who could one day you know Dethrone
us or overtake us
essentially yeah I got another note here
on um ssr's anti-depressants therapy and
baggage and one of the things I noticed
was that the younger the woman
is the you know it's interesting because
it's like a you know it's like a bell
curve the younger she has the less
baggage she she's got at some point
there's like a middle point where it's
like they've been carrying baggage
around for quite a while late 30 like
late 20s maybe 30s you know in some
cases and then at some point and they
deal with it when they're past their
Prime and they're in their 40s and and
you know 50s where they don't tend to
sort of carry that baggage around so
much did you notice that Trend with the
you know a couple of the gals there's
there's a few that were very very like
distraught during the conversations and
they were talking about therapy and
ssris and anti-depressants and stuff
like that that they were
on yeah I found that particularly
interesting because statistically the
women that are most likely to be on
anti-depressants ssris are white single
women that are 40 plus yeah not your
late 20s early 30s so we had a few in
the late 20s that were on
anti-depressant we did we did and I
think so I think they're kind of
reaching that critical mass whether you
want to call it biological clock if you
want to call it the Epiphany phase
whether whether you want to call it the
wall it doesn't really matter what you
want to call it I think a lot of the
women in their 40s and 50s sort
of resigned to their plight and they
kind of just said hey this is how it's
going to be and they kind of rationalize
it in a way so they don't have to go
through that but I don't I don't want to
say maybe they've given up hope but it's
they seem to say they seem to be much
more comfortable with reality and
knowing and being more self-aware um
because they've I think they've had
enough time and experience in the real
world where they no longer get that
attention the guys they want are not
going after them anymore and so they
just becomes a very sobering reality
whereas the women in their late 20s
early 30s are doing everything they can
to claw back to when they were 22 23 and
keep those feelings and so they're
they're unable to reconcile the fact
that they are on borrowed time and that
the know Sands in The Hourglass are
spilling
rapidly um and so they're not quite
ready to embrace and accept um and I
think it's probably also a generational
thing as well I
mean I mean even last week or two weeks
I mean the first thing those I mean the
two 21 year olds we had on we're talking
about therapy right and it's just such a
mainstream thing now I mean you have
major podcast platforms that are
sponsored by like tella Health Therapy
companies better health or exactly yeah
so um it is incredibly mainstream it is
you know very jenzy and very Millennial
focused I don't think that it permeated
Gen X as much as it has the younger
Generations
so um yeah it's definitely interesting I
but I I I thought most of the time like
when we had 40y old 50y old women on
they were rather well adjusted um even
though they may be single moms or they
may be um going through a divorce or
separated I they still tended to
be a little more you know head on their
shoulders than a lot of the younger
chicks I think it's because they at some
point come to the realization that the
expiry date on their beauty is a lot
closer than what they had anticipated in
the past like we had
um uh Martha Bueno was her name or
something like that yeah I don't know if
you remember her with the oh I remember
Martha she had the uh she had the she
had the sign above her she had the neon
sign
yeah yeah Latin Latin boss babe um was
the title of that one and see people
break my balls over my neon sign but at
least mine doesn't say MTH in the
background like yeah I mean give me a
break yeah she was um yeah she was
interesting because you know she was in
her 40s and she wanted to argue that um
that uh she was just as valuable and
just as attractive today in the sexual
Marketplace as she was when she was in
her early 20s and we did a poll on the
community Tab and had thousands and
thousands of responses and I just you
know cuz we met her on Twitter and I
just took one of of her earlier
photographs which she posted in her
timeline in the argument that you know
she wanted to kick up with us of her
when she was like 20 or something like
that versus her today and uniformly
unanimously across the board everybody
thought she looked better younger and
it's like at some point I think you know
women come to or they arrive at this
place where they're like yeah I probably
was a lot more beautiful when I was 23
and me not being
as beautiful and having baggage is
probably costing me and then that's when
they're willing to put down the baggage
and walk away from it um you guys let me
know what you think if that you know
meets your own experiences throw it in
the comments but I think that you know
the notion of of of baggage and I mean
like even even the ssris like I was
actually surprised how open and willing
some of these gals were to admit that
they are on anti-depressants I mean your
ex-girlfriend was on anti-depressants
like you did an entire show oh yeah on
sort of like what led you up on them
office hours to you know getting red
pilled and finding all this stuff and
you know connecting with me and it's
like you know the stories you were
telling about you know the ups and downs
and you pop you know these pills in the
morning and these pills at night and the
Sleep patterns and like the sexual
function and the desire and the weight
goes like it throws everything off for
women it's it's it's really not a good
place to be and like you know the
willingness to say I mean they're not
saying hey I'm [__] but they're
basically saying hey I'm admitting that
I'm on these things but it kind of numbs
them doesn't it like it like it sort of
makes them like these gray Blobs of
nothingness right where they don't have
any polarity it's just they're just you
know they just are and they don't care
well what's interesting is that I think
the reason that they're so forthcoming
about it is because it's not taboo
anymore it's mainstream it's acceptable
it's almost it's celebrated and it's
funny to be a chick that's messed up in
the head I mean you've got I I had had
um a conversation with with my girl
maybe a week ago where she used to
listen to that call her daddy podcast
and not very seriously I think she just
listened to it but they used to sell
merchandise and like on the shirts they
would said something like I'm unwell
right and it's it's h it's funny it's
like oh I'm so messed up oh I'm so
quirky my life is a joke like hahaa and
I was like think about the message that
you're putting out into the world like
think about when you put something on a
shirt and you're going wear that in
public what you're sending to people
right you know and you might just say oh
you're just being a hard ass it's just a
funny little thing but the stories we
tell ourselves are real the things we
choose to broadcast as signals and
messages to other people and strangers
are absolutely real and so if you're not
careful you become numb to those signals
and they become a part of your everyday
reality and so always tired always
depressed always my life isn't a tail
span hahaa my life is such a train wreck
and
you start to embody some of those traits
and and carry that stuff around and it's
it's almost like
a it's like a badge of honor or it makes
them it makes them want like almost it's
almost like an ingroup thing it's well
if nothing else I'm super alone but at
least there's a million other women out
there that are as screwed up as me so it
makes me feel a little bit better about
myself because at least I'm not the only
one so uh yeah the ssris and the drugs
and and all of that sort of stuff is
just I it's become at this point you
know it's celebrated it's get it's go to
therapy and get on drugs I mean it's
it's yeah it's really
sickening it's um it's almost like women
celebrate ssris like men celebrate
trt trt has a much more positive effect
on men than SSR do on women I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out